je voudrais aujourd'hui qu'on se parle
de secret de marque je vous ai fait ça
il ya quelques jours sur shia aux mille
et ce chrétien au mit et on va se parler
de secret de samsung alors s'annonce
longue vous le savez vous connaissez la
marque c'est aujourd'hui le numéro un
sur la téléphonie mobile mais pas que et
c'est une énorme boîte qui est coréenne
jusque là on le sait et on va apprendre
plein de choses sur samsung sûrement des
choses que vous connaissez son amarre y
en a d'autres que vous ne connaissez pas
et que vous allez découvrir dans cette
vidéo donc regardez la bien jusqu'au
bout pour savoir tous les secrets de
samsung et pouvoir vous la péter devant
vos potes mais ça c'est bien allez on y
va
alors j'ai pris plein de notes j'ai
voilà tout est là dessus vous en
douterez la première chose c'est je sais
pas si vous le savez d'ailleurs voulais
le dire en commentaire est ce que vous
savez ce que veut dire samsung ne
trichez pas n'allez pas plus loin mais
tu es une petite pause et marque dans
les commentaires selon vous que veut
dire samsung à les y aller on a deux
trois petites secondes 1,2 à amy n'a pas
haussé bon 3 ok on y va vous savez que
ça veut dire samsung en fait ça me
semble ça veut dire trois étoiles 3
étoiles 3 étoiles qu'en fait il ya
plusieurs choses ça fait déjà référence
au nom de la marque en coréen ok ça
évoque aussi la volonté de produire des
produits de qualité tels que samsung
fabrique des produits de qualité comme
son fondateur de la choisit voulait
également dire qu'il voulait que la
marque deviennent puissante et dure
éternellement et puis ensuite le chiffre
3 c'est un symbole très particuliers en
corée ça permet d'affirmer de la
grandeur et la puissance donc on est
vraiment dans cette idée de dire ok je
crée cette marque je l'appelle samsung
mais les trois étoiles elle va avoir de
la grandeur elle va avoir de la
puissance et elle va aller loin dans le
temps c'est vraiment ça il s'est pas
planté pourquoi parce qu'en fait samsung
enfin le groupe ne débute samsung
comment nous d'être un énorme groupe
s'était fondée en
1938 il n'y a pas tout à fait un siècle
mais presque
1938 vous vous rendez compte et au début
ça n'avait rien à voir électronique
c'était une société de négoce ont été
dans l'alimentaire on était très loin
des samsung galaxy des tablettes des
écrans et de tout ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui très très loin alors ça me
saoule vous le savez c'est pas
aujourd'hui uniquement des fabricants de
smartphones l'alimentaire c'est une
vieille histoire et sont plus du tout
fait samsung ce groupe c le groupe
samsung est divisé en plusieurs
divisions sont vraiment ou segmenté
alors j'ai pas tous voulaient pas tout
de suite parce que d'une je n'y connais
pas tout épisode semble très compliqué
c'est qu'on connaît le plus et samsung
electronics -qui fabriquent vos
smartphones vos tablettes vos écrans et
compagnie tout le côté fabrication de
l'écran quand ils vont être intégrés
dans les smartphones c'est une autre
entité qui s'appelle samsung display est
votre avis sur de la recherche et
développement sur les écrans qui se plie
sur les écrans l'aide sur le mini l'aide
tout ça bref donc là c'est vraiment que
l'écran le groupe samsung a également
racheté il ya quelques années le groupe
harman arman harman kardon de l'époque
très groupe harman qui détient notamment
jbl à kg bang & olufsen dont voyez on
est énorme on est dans l'électronique
grand public au niveau de l'audio là
dessus ils sont également présents au
niveau des semi conducteurs bah oui
fabrique notamment le processeur exynos
les processeur exynos qu'on connaît tous
les ans dans les smartphones de la gamme
s ils sont également présents dans le
btp et ouais on ne s'attendrait pas
forcément mais ils sont là dedans
fabriquer des tours et compagnie mais
également dans les chantiers navals
samsung heavy industries co ok mais
également dans l'automobile a été créée
en 1995 samsung motors qui a été repris
en 2000 par renault qui s'appelle
maintenant renault samsung motors et ça
je l'avais vu quand j'étais allé en
corée ce mardi surpris dont vous voyez
comme quoi qu'on retrouve samsung un peu
partout et l'âge n'ont vraiment qu'une
petite partie en tout cas de l'idée mais
c'est assez énorme on voit que samsung a
été créée en 1938 mais l'électronique
n'a commencé qu'à arriver quasiment 30
ans après quasiment en 1960 est le
premier produit qu'ils ont sorti c'est
une télé noir et blanc et oui à l'époque
et pas la couleur forcément s'en doutera
ils sont bien rattrapés depuis chiffre
assez marrant j'ai quelques chiffres en
2007 samsung est le troisième fabricant
mondial de téléphones portables derrière
qui vous donne dans le mille on est en
2007 derrière nokia et motorola à
l'époque je pas si vous êtes déjà un
dino de l'époque où si vous le savez est
bien les grands leaders des téléphones
portables c'était pas le smartphone on
parle bien de téléphone portable c'était
nokia et motorola nokia avec le fameux
snake sais pas si vous avez joué 33
suspense était énorme à l'époque et
c'est qu'en 2012 que samsung est passé
numéro un la téléphonie mobile également
au niveau des smartphones c'est énorme
alors je comprenne un peu le logo de
samsung puisque je vous en parle ce logo
avec trois étoiles il a été décliné il a
été revu dans le temps il a évolué si
vous regardez la première version est
sortie en 1938 jusqu'à 1969 hier pendant
30 ans et bien vous voyez trois étoiles
c'est un logo qui est très très loin de
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui mais ok on
en suit une évolution de 1969 à 1979 ont
toujours que ces fameux trois étoiles
qui apparaissent 1979 à 1993 toujours
les 3 étoiles et ensuite 1993 à 2014 les
étoiles ont disparu on est sur un logo
avec un espèce d'aspe un peu ovale qu'on
va retrouver tout autour alors en fait
ce côté ovale ça veut dire quoi eh bien
ça montre la galaxie ils vont vraiment
dans l'idée de la galaxie pillay à
l'action la route plus tard
effectivement dans cette gamme de
smartphones samsung galaxy et on voit qu
elle ne s et le g qui dépasse légèrement
envoyé de l'ovale l'idée c'est de venir
se dire ok eaux dépasse de la galaxie on
vient repousser les limites
technologiques ça montre une fois de
plus l'idée est là envie de la marque
d'innover et d'aller beaucoup plus loin
bon c'est un peu mégalo en attendant son
leader donc on peut pas leur en vouloir
et puis en 2014 ça change complètement
on part sur un truc beaucoup plus simple
les lettres écrit en grand et on l'avait
déjà vu arriver ça en 93 y avait la
barre du hac avait disparu qui est
toujours absente en le nouveau logo qui
est apparue en 2014 et qui continue
aujourd'hui à perdurer en 2022 ouais on
est en 2022 aujourd'hui c'est ça on s'en
souvenir des fois alors ça me semble que
c'est énorme samsung ses 550 mille
brevets déposés dont 330 milles actifs
actuellement c'est énorme est ce que
vous savez ce que veut dire le s dans
samsung galaxy s est-ce que vous avez
une idée de ça je sais pas si vous avez
une idée alors y'a pas un truc vraiment
officiellement il ya quelques années
samsung nous a dit ça semble vouloir
dire ça si vous le savez si vous avez
votre idée une fois de plus vous mettez
la pause et voulu marquer en bas en
commentaire très curieux allez jouer
deux ou trois petites secondes 1 2 3 en
fait ça me semble à quelques années a
dit le s peuvent vouloir dire super
smart ses smart c'est bien c'était super
produit de super qualité alors il n'y a
rien eu d'officiel ça a été dit a
longtemps aujourd'hui on n'a aucune
appellation ce qu'on sait juste si vous
regardez galaxy s s on est dans le plus
haut de gamme c'est la gamme photo et
vidéo il ya encore au dessus de la gamme
galaxy z là c'est plus l'innovation et
celle pliable mais galaxy s on est dans
le top du top avec effectivement un gros
focus sur la photo et la vidéo vous avez
parlé de chiffres j'en ai un qui est
vachement bien en 2019 2019 s'est pas si
vieux que ça samsung compte et dans le
monde pas moins de 300
8745 employés était la 13e entreprise la
plus importante dans le monde entier
selon le classement de forbes c'est
juste colossal autre chiffre qui pèse un
peu et bien c'est un chiffre que j'ai
qui date de 2017 j'ai pas de chiffres
plus récents c'est le chiffre d'affaires
de samsung en 2017 accrochez-vous 1 226
milliards de dollars qui était le
deuxième derrière apple on se marre bien
de chiffre d'affaires alors toutes
filiales confondues on se parle ici
effectivement du groupe samsung c'est
juste voilà et puis samsung fournit
également d'autres marques notamment au
travers de batteries lithium ion de semi
conducteurs de mémoire flash deux
disques durs d'écran et compagnie ils
fournissent notamment apple sony htc
nokia pour ne parler que d'eux comme je
le disais au début samsung c'est une
grosse entité avec plein de marques avec
plein de produits et bien ça me saoule
fabriquer des disques durs oui
absolument et en 2011 samsung
electronics a vendu toute sa partie
disque dur et l'ont vendu à qui ils ont
vendu à 6 gates et bah oui aujourd'hui
une des références gates au niveau des
disques durs pour 1,4 milliard de
dollars la moitié en numéraire et la
moitié en actions si gates alors ça me
semble aussi quelques casseroles il ya
eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
réussite et la plupart c'est de l'art
est il qu'on va retrouver au niveau des
ventes au niveau de l'innovation et au
niveau de tous qui vont vous proposer
aujourd'hui en tout cas et puis ces
dernières années du côté technologique
mais il ya eu aussi quelques petites
plantade notamment au niveau du samsung
galaxy note 7 on l'a vu c'était le
smartphone avec la batterie qui dans
certains cas explose et qui a donc été
bannie au niveau des avions et samsung a
tout récupéré iota tap-tap top on arrête
on reprend les smartphones ya eu un
retrait du produit et puis il faut dire
quand même que l'action de samsung à un
peu dévissé à ce moment-là compliqué
l'histoire alors se continuer de
progresser il ya plus problème mais
quelques années après c'était en 2019 il
ya eu un problème avec le lancement
souvenez vous souvenez vous je vous
l'avais montré avec le samsung galaxy
fold le premier smartphone pliable
montrer de façon intéressante parce
qu'on a vu un petit peu avant qui avait
été montrée par une autre marque mais
qui était pas dingue le galaxy fold il
avait un petit problème enfin beau
problème même c'est qu'en fait je sais
pas si vous le savez mais souvent
lorsqu'on va faire des tests smartphone
on vient enlever la protection d'écran
que vous avez sur le dessus pour
vraiment voir l'écran nunettes et bien
c'est ce qu'ont fait les médias
américains lorsqu'ils l'ont reçue ils
ont vu tien on peut venir enlever de la
protection ils ont tiré dessus sauf qu
est ce qui s'est passé bien fait c'était
pas une protection d'écran c'était une
partie intégrante de l'écran et pensant
enlever une protection d'écran ils ont
arraché et abîmé à l'écran ce qui fait
que leurs smartphones étaient
inutilisables avec un affichage qui
était mort donc il ya un côté un peu bad
buzz là-dessus samsung a récupéré ces
unités a dit ok ok on va regarder ils
ont retravaillé dessus et on a vu
arriver c'était au tout début de
l'automne femmes d'été des bulles
l'automne 2010 neuf et bien une nouvelle
version du samsung galaxy fold revue
travailler avec un écran complètement
optimisé après une très très belle
évolution et puis on a vu effectivement
le succès ce smartphone parce que je
trouve une fois de plus super
intéressant avec la dernière version qui
est sorti il ya pas longtemps samsung
galaxy z folle de trois voiliers est-ce
que vous connaissiez ses secrets de cinq
sous alors garde à d'autres j'ai regardé
un jeu phu yên et j'ai fait ma tête
chercheuse de tous les côtés j'ai vu pas
mal d'autres choses aussi intéressante
peut-être qu'on fera une deuxième vie
pour venir parler des secrets de samsung
si vous le voulez si ça vous intéresse
double marque est bien évidemment
commentaires puis il ya une autre
question à vous poser est ce que vous
souhaiteriez qu'on parle d'une marque en
particulier au niveau des secrets est ce
qu'il ya une idée qui vous vient en tête
est ce que vous avez des envies si oui
vous voulez marquer bien évidemment en
bas en commentaire je vais regarder tout
ça et puis moi d'ici là qu'est-ce que je
fais là je vous embrasse fait de passer
une excellente fin de journée beaucoup
d'amour prenez soin de vous et à très
vite des bijoux beaucoup d'amour taquin
[Musique]
oui